you might have some trouble getting back
from a vacation getting to a business
trip even getting here to to nashville
for our backstage show tomorrow i got a
very sad message i got an instagram from
someone
who was unpacking her bag because she
had booked a flight to come to
nashville for the backstage show she
bought her ticket but she couldn't come
because
a lot of airlines notably southwest
airlines
is canceling a ton of flights just
yesterday
southwest canceled more than a thousand
flights a thousand flights 25
more than 25 of all the flights they had
that day
now the airline hasn't explained why
they canceled the flights they tried to
kind of blame it on weather
but i don't think it was weather
i'm skeptical that it was weather
i suspect
they're trying to recover our operation
because of a reported and rumored
employee sickout
that employees not just of of southwest
but of
a lot of other airlines
are protesting the vaccine mandate
because
while one may might make the prudential
judgment to get the vaccine right they
might say oh my risk from the vaccine is
not so great and my risk from the virus
might be a little high so okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna take the risk i'm gonna get
the vaccine and plenty of people have
done that and ostensibly they seem like
they're completely fine but other
employees might say you know i'm healthy
i'm young
there is some risk of the vaccine i'm
not so afraid of my risk from the virus
so i'm not going to get it and you
southwest and you osha and you joe biden
are not going to make me get it
so they're protesting it and now the
flights are canceled and that's too bad
and i'm very sorry for people whose
flights are canceled and i travel all
the time by airplane and i bet some of
my flights are going to be canceled too
and that's going to be very inconvenient
but this is actually great news and the
great news is this the people still have
a lot of power
the people still have the ruling class
has taken a ton of political power a
disproportionate amount of political
power
that's true in big tech it's true in the
government it's true in corporations
it's true in the schools they they are
punching above their weight in terms of
their political power but the people
still have some power too
and if you just don't go along with this
stuff
and you do so in a respectful dignified
moral way but you just don't really go
along with the overreaches of these
of these predator
ruling class oligarchs
you're still going to have some power
and they're they're really going to get
upset when they're when their flights do
not show up on time i am so glad
it makes me feel very good to know that
you liked that clip and that's cool you
can leave a little comment click the
like subscribe that's great but you can
get the whole show okay the entire
michael knowles show podcast you can get
it for free right here at youtube or if
you want the audio experience without
any of the censorship that occasionally
accompanies this
wonderful platform head on over apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
myspace xanga
aol instant messenger go subscribe to
the michael knowles show podcast see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you